welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david today if you want
more from me you can find me on youtube
on my two channels youtube.com slash the
ring of fire and youtube.com
fair and balanced i'm also on twitter
facebook and instagram at fair and
balanced on all three accounts easy
enough to find right
let's get right back into some of
today's top stories uh one of the ones
that i definitely have to talk about
here mostly because
look i'm sitting in florida's first
congressional district my congressman is
matt gates one of the most embarrassing
members of congress out there
and matt gates is having a tough go of
it recently
obviously embroiled in this potential uh
you know underage sex trafficking
scandal still under investigation for
that now last week of course
and i believe uh jessie dolamore who was
filling in for pacman talked about this
a little so i'm only going to hit on
this part briefly but yes last week we
found out that joel greenberg the former
seminole county tax collector has been
cooperating with federal authorities
giving them thousands of pages
that includes pictures and of course
there's some videos mixed in there as
well
text messages private conversations all
kinds of information some of it that
does appear to directly implicate matt
gates
in this scandal
so that's really bad for him
but even that aside let's assume for a
moment that matt gates wasn't under
investigation and matt gates was still
going about doing his matt gates stuff
believe it or not here in florida's very
red first congressional district
things are not all rosy for matt gates
in fact republicans in this district are
growing tired of his antics
they're getting tired of the fact
that the guy as one republican put it
actually a republican who plans the
primary gates says
he's everywhere but here
matt gates is neglecting
his district
and one former party chair from this
area
expressed his concern
saying that
we need somebody that actually cares we
need somebody that comes back matt gates
has not held an event in this district
since march
so here we are
you know over five months later
and matt gates has been out to
california
he's been in the midwest he's been in
the southeast or southwest
he's been in south florida
he's been everywhere but here as they
say
he doesn't want to come home
now don't get me wrong matt gates still
enjoys a lot of support in this district
and barring any indictments against him
he's going to win re-election
that is a given
the point is there's cracks in the
facade
just a few cracks at this point
but those cracks are growing
and the republicans here republicans
with a voice
are starting to get annoyed by the fact
that he is neglecting this
district
we had last year hurricane sally come
through here
sally
knocked out
a bridge
that was the main artery for traffic
between two cities actually my city
right here
and
where my actual ring of fire studio is
so we had to drive an hour out of the
way because that bridge was gone all of
those businesses on either end of that
bridge
ended up closing down some permanently
some temporarily that bridge which was
knocked out uh i believe last september
is when the storm came through was only
reopened
the last week of may of this year
millions of dollars in economic revenue
lost because uh the bridge got knocked
down
we had republican state leaders coming
here all the time
talking about it trying to hold the
company skanska accountable because they
actually had left their barges not tied
up when the hurricane came through and
those barges are what got swept into the
bridge and knocked it down so those
republicans came here
acted like they cared
matt gates was nowhere to be seen
his district was literally in crisis
following a hurricane dude didn't care
wasn't out here demanding justice wasn't
out here trying to fight skanska for
their neglect over there nothing
just going on fox news as frequently as
possible which he's not even welcome
there anymore
because that's what matt gates wants to
do
and that's what people in this district
need to understand
i firmly believe
that matt gates's end goal is not to
be president of the united states
heck it's not even to be a senator he
doesn't care as much about political
power what he cares about
is fame and popularity
that is why obviously earlier this year
we had all those reports of matt gates
reaching out to networks saying hey
would you hire me as a as a pundit would
you hire me as a talking head can i have
a show
that's why two weeks ago he launched his
new podcast video podcast
firebrand with matt gates
that's what the guy wants to do he he
wants this
and matt buddy let me tell you man
if this is what you want
resign
or simply don't run for re-election just
let the clock run out and go and be the
bestest republican talking head you can
be
get yourself a camera we already know
you built a studio in your dad's house
use that studio
put your videos on youtube i'm sure you
would gain millions of subscribers in a
matter of weeks you'd make a ton of
money having that many people follow you
you could sell subscriptions you could
get advertisers you could do whatever
the heck you wanted you would have more
money in fame than you could ever
imagine and after all isn't that what
you want
but instead in order to get to that
point
you're taking up a congressional seat
you're literally getting nothing done in
washington d.c you're traveling the
country with one of the most despised
members of congress out there marjorie
taylor green you're an embarrassment to
this district and to the entire state of
florida and you're doing it all so you
can build up your brand
so that you can hopefully sell it when
you leave office
if of course you're not sitting in a
jail cell by the time it all comes
crashing down
that's the problem that matt gates faces
but don't worry folks this district is
safe for republicans and i think that's
why they're not putting up that much of
a stink right now
if they thought they had a democrat that
could come along and win this district
they would absolutely be encouraging
gates to step down get replaced by a
different republican so that they could
put all their eggs in that basket
but they know that whatever happens to
gates a republican will come behind him
and win the seat regardless or gates
himself will continue to win it
that's why they're not worried